[Musica]
ragazzi ragazze e persone di questo
mondo siamo tornati perché lo avesse
visto il video precedente ho sfidato i
tre volte campione italiano di overwatch
non ho vinto ma eravamo lì lì per
arrivare alla supremazia in questo caso
il campione italiano o virus e thomas
quante volte sei stato non mi ricordo
mai tre volte campioni si come me più o
meno siccome oggi è un giorno speciale
perché in realtà era un po che non
prendo ammazzato su qualcosa
volevo provare a riprendersi la
rivincita con thomas e quindi siamo di
nuovo in 1 v1 su overwatch allora io con
tutta la calma nel mondo ti dico che mi
sono allenato in questi giorni ho fatto
niente altro che giocare da esterni un
aspetto allora però deve capire che
se vuoi una o due posso fartele fare ma
poche perché ho bisogno di pace
d'accordo ma facciamo per fare bene va
bene allora come potete vedere il
livello è lo stesso ha differito solo
lui al tipo 14 livelli in più le stelle
sotto una sera prestare 3000 rita la
verità funzione tra l'altro siamo stati
noi senza punteggio a oltranza
quando ti stanchi di morire vabbè allora
ti la stazione qualche festa
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta la vasca
ok ok ok allora che amiamoci un secondo
allora per gli amici si parte con 5 di
vita si fa così proprio per agevolare il
proprio amico questa è un'usanza quando
l'hanno fatto l'uno a zero iniziale
serve soltanto per dare il punto di
vantaggio alle persone più scarse quindi
io che sono un gentleman chiama proprio
facile ama tra l'altro ci fanno usare
sempre lo stesso personaggio e cela
abbiamo lo stesso personaggio fighissimo
mi piace un sacco sta roba
ok partiamo ciao che bello allora è
gioco over voci tutti i giorni quindi la
mia skill leggenda in questo gioco qui
non ti stupire sentimento della
pressione tranquillo gioca come
ma io pensi mi
ovviamente ti avevo visto non pensavo
avessi un'arma da dove è entrato e non
ho capito dove il tuo punto di partenza
comunque dai 20 è ancora fattivi
attenzione attenzione ma come fai a voi
fidano di me perché levi di più allora
qua 6 orbo non vedi
siccome non vedi dovrebbe andare tutto
giusto no non so che cosa sto facendo la
prima volta chiuso questo personaggio da
noi sono felice se è così
cos'è quella roba lì l'hack è male ma
c'ero anch'io come si fa con l'assist a
aiac e botte in faccia forte se lo
sentiva veramente un'altra di casera e
cade fatto un volo di chi vi inizia
adesso
togliamo tutti le cose mi ha fatto
inediti in parte appello a tutti i
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
io sono fa vj e oggi siamo su overwatch
con thomas che campione tre volte dio
avremo cio gli faccio vedere come sono
forte a questo gioco qua e gli spiego
gli spiego come funziona allora ho preso
un gioco per joker il professore di san
giocare e devi fare il culo agli altri
come sto facendo io allora così l'esatta
reserva fare wine bar che ricacciano in
stazione beh no aspetta è partito il
della partitissima bene a tutti i
ragazzi e benvenuti avessero video io
sono fa vj e ci siamo dati su overwatch
con thomas che tre volte campioni
italiani di over ward è una bella
giornata perché oggi insegnerò a thomas
come si gioca overwatch è un gioco
fantastico perché amo toma sei pronto
sono prontissimo vai e bellissima cosa
ho fatto
alaia calmati ho capito che potevo
aspetta aspetta e 3 recuperi vita con lo
shift recupero vita ottimo buono a
sapersi alla e la e donna
la donna non arriva non me la ricordavo
stato ok bene a posto
ragazzi l'obiettivo di oggi sarà fare
almeno una kill a thomas cioè io che
dovevo far fare lui deve fare a meno una
kill
io le farò tutto fare tutte le altre
come sempre fatto qua vedo vedo i tuoi
cosi che si è passato ma non vedo tech
come si chiama quel cartone animato
della pizza che si spara i ghiacci che
dalla frozen quella che cammina no no no
e se era frozen è sì
non so perché l'ho visto bene donal
piacciono le donald trump
l'hack è male ma come funziona ragazzi
no no no no so più spesso ragazzi spero
lievito vi sia piaciuto
questa è l'unica cosa l'unica partita
che faremo durante tutto il video spero
che il video vi sia piaciuto come potete
vedere un 1 a 0 poi non andiamo avanti
perché potremmo umiliare troppo
l'avversario
quindi va bene così video si è concluso
lasciate mi piace
adesso la gente si sarà stancato e non
vedo il resto del videoclip giocare
tranquilli bene ma ho capito che avevo
pensato di fare questa cosa ma non
pensavo di riuscirci sul serio è stato
wow mi vale un po come se fosse il
campione italiano per un secondo noi è
durato molto meno vive qui nel pozzo con
qualche eroe ma non mi piace si
immetterà non capisco come si fanno le
cose
ahi ahi che male forte vorrebbe proviamo
questa da doveri si svuota volo visto
colpendo una morto varrà qualcosa a
quando capì york a che sei tu sei qua
segno kissi ma è piaciuta la skin di
uovo è un hosting di warcraft premi
shift guarda non ti pago adesso perché
sarebbe brutto ma se i premi shift
diventi visibile e poi bono troveremo
non ci troviamo più perché se vedranno
invisibili ed è verissimo
c'è un sacco di comandi dunque aspetta
che non so ok a parte che diventa
visibile poi non ci troviamo più però
attenzione si incontrano aia ricca null
aerei ad allora aspetta aspetta
scherzando scherzando che male non
diventa più visibile bagato lo lascia
una datazione la mano sinistra che crea
dei piccoli triangoli servono qualcosa
mi faccio solo gnocca oppure no puoi
hackerare l'avversario avere anche
prendere di instagram ed è ma da dove
minc ieri hai usato in visivi madonna è
bellissimo si sa un bel sembra veramente
un assassin's creed
ok ho questo con questo si guardi nel
pozzo sei pronto lezione noi si fa qui
si fa con lo chef non va a blitz che lo
aspettava
la donna chiama le chiama le forte no si
è salvato grazie
cosa è accaduto prima io avresti vinto
no non è vero noi o convinto che
prendendo ti saresti caduto prima tu no
ma dai
cavolo erdan già creato una grande folla
tissimo sporca che ero convinto becca
testa pugno no c'è ma se ci riprovo un
milione di volte non riesco duro se ci
riprova ti prego fatemi rivedere quella
roba lì che stai veramente più orribile
di quella delle macchine dove sono morte
sono caduto anche questa guarda la
pratica è stata richiesta dai come
abbiamo fatto
guarda come ti anticipo lì e tu guarda
del caduto prima io poi tu mi tiri su no
però anche un mito di buttarti giù detto
mica l'ho fatto io no ora che comunque
la prima ho fatta da una l'ho fatta
comunque io vorrei aggiungere una cosa
l'ultima volta che abbiamo giocato ne
aveva fatti di bo 20 e su 20 nei mint 19
io una adesso già vinto se ne vinco
un'altra superò il mio record capito
l'altra è record fatto quindi not dead
vabbè
chi è quello veramente fatto è messo il
disco non pensavo lo sapesse usare a
maggio il dischord cos'è il disco che
rovina che mi deve trovarsi mourinho che
il sito non è il nostro primo incontro
non avrei messo trovavo ma che non lo sa
usare usato perché sono impegnato
tantissimo nuovo record due chi la
thomas può basta sul potendo così non so
come si faccia roba cerco demonio e lo
fa volare giù sospettato di aggrapparmi
a qualcosa no raga io direi che potrei
cruiser l'acqua anche se è stato molto
censita concluso qua e ti va bene che
sono
grazie grazie per avermi risparmiato
prego prego chiamata un sarà lo stesso
per ragazzi che vi sia piaciuto
ringrazio tom per aver partecipato al
video grazie a te a una descrizione però
inizia piaciuto ragazzi qualsiasi di
cemento mi piace anche ricerche
descrizione sono questi schiavi e non ci
vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]